hi welcome to another cold fusion video
htc holds a very special place in my
heart
during my brief stint in tech reviews i
used to review and modify htc
phones while studying at university in
2009
in fact the very first video that made
me consider taking youtube a bit more
seriously
featured an htc phone it was partly how
this channel started
htc understood design and attention to
detail
they reminded me of the old-school
traditional apple methodology
but in the android world chances are
if you owned one you loved it htc
were a more influential player in the
smartphone market than you might think
they made the first ever android phone
they also designed google's nexus
devices
and at one point they were the largest
android phone manufacturer
and the largest smartphone vendor in the
united states
yes even bigger than apple but as of
today
their last phone was in may of 2018 and
they've completely vanished from the
public's consciousness
so how did this happen let's go back to
a time before samsung and the plethora
of android devices
a time when the mobile space was very
different
let's see the rise and fall of htc
[Music]
you are watching cold fusion tv
this is chia wang she was born in 1958
in taiwan
and studied in the united states in 1981
she graduated from the university of
california with a bachelor's degree in
economics
the next year she would join the
taiwanese firm first international
computer
and here she learned much about business
operations
[Music]
many years later in 1997 chi wang had
the desire to start her own company
and out of this high-tech corporation or
htc
was born initially htc was a
manufacturer of notebook computers
but just a year later the firm would
begin designing some of the world's
first
touch and wireless handheld devices
early in my career
showing off pc multiple performance to
customers
all over europe back then not too many
people
had a personal computer within a few
years
most of people has won
while i was dragging my 25 kilo
computers
up and down the train across europe
quite exhausted i saw the dream about
a small computer that fits into my hand
that i could use to call my friends or
listen to music
as soon as window c came out
i started htc with my partners
to achieve their dream a former work
colleague of wang
peter chao took over a ceo in 2004
and from here htc started making windows
mobile pdas and smartphones
chi wang would come back later in the
story
in 2008 htc released the world's first
device powered by android
the htc dream
in the same year they would release the
first american 4g smartphone
and then they went on to design google's
first hardware phone
the nexus 1 in 2010
ceo peter chow was known for his quick
decision making
and also his perfectionist mentality he
would take
trays of smartphones at his desk and
check every detail
was the finish on the edges of the phone
perfect did the joints of the phone
line up with precision other staff would
note that this was obsessive attention
to detail
but on the other hand peter would
criticize management decisions and
override them with little discussion
this would later turn out to be a major
problem within the walls of htc
but for now they were flying high
[Music]
in november of 2009 the company released
the htc
hd2 it was the world's first windows
mobile device with a capacitive
touchscreen
before this all windows phones are a
resistive touch making them clunky and
hard to use
this very phone was the device that
started some initial buzz around the
cold fusion channel
the htc hd2 phone had a cult following
and some online forums took great
interest in the modifications i made to
the phone
the resulting video views made me
realize that there might be something to
this whole youtube thing
so in a way i owe something to the
company
in 2010 htc was named one of the most
innovative companies in the world
they were definitely a worthy rival for
apple in the united states and europe
so why were they so successful
well the company cared about design both
in hardware and software
their phones felt premium in your hand
they were well proportioned and designed
often sculpted from unibody brushed
aluminium
this was important it was htc and not
apple they introduced a unibody metal
design
apple would later copy htc
remember this was at a time when android
smartphones were still plastic
the company was also featuring stereo
speakers at a time when sound was an
afterthought for many manufacturers
htc was well ahead of their time in this
regard
the attention to detail by ceo peter
chow was paying off
[Music]
the second half of the successful design
philosophy was in software
windows mobile was a big deal in 2009
although the interface was basically an
ugly spreadsheet
to address this htc created a software
skin that ran on top of windows mobile
called touch flow 3d and it turned the
boring spreadsheet look
into something engaging and fun
as the world moved from windows mobile
to android the touchflow 3d software
would turn into htc sense and it did
wonders for android at the time
because android was a mess htc
sense cleaned up a lot of the issues and
gaps that existed
users loved it and the phones gained
widespread acclaim
at this point around 2010 htc
were on top of the world so how did it
go all so wrong
samsung was looking at what htc had
accomplished and they decided to make
their own themed android home screen
calling it touchwiz the samsung galaxy s
in 2010
marked this change next samsung began
flooding the market with their devices
htc and samsung both began to release
phone after phone
in a battle for supremacy but with
deeper pockets and better marketing
samsung's advantage quickly began to
show
2010 was a pivotal time for the
smartphone industry
the general public was beginning to wake
up to the fact that smartphones weren't
just another pda
they were actually changing the world
the smartphone boom was just beginning
and as a company
you had two options hit to ride or be
left behind
samsung was still largely unknown at the
time but they were coming up fast
if htc weren't careful it wouldn't be
apple vs htc
but samsung versus apple the correct
thing for htc to do
would be to double down on mobile poor
money into research and development
advertising everything and anything to
solidify their market position
instead they did something bizarre
they lost focus and they invested in
unrelated markets
first the company bought s3 graphics a
pc manufacturer
the deal failed to create any new
hardware for htc
phones for their own company or to
license to other smartphone makers
htc then looked to streaming content
investing nearly 90 million dollars and
two streaming providers
on live and saffron neither venture was
fruitful
in 2011 htc took a 51
stake in beats electronics for 300
million dollars
they sold it for a profit of 56 million
dollars two years later
just a year later in 2014 apple came
along and bought beads for 3 billion
i guess htc were just trying to make
bets to diversify
but all of these ventures ended up
failing
while htc were spinning their wheels
throwing money at things that wouldn't
help
samsung was using its huge manufacturing
arsenal
they got to work providing displays and
flash memory for both their phones and
for other major players such as
apple's iphones and even htc's phones
while samsung's market share grew its
whole honest competitors also became
stronger
the korean company chipped away at htc's
dominance
bit by bit
admittedly these punches would have been
difficult for htc to handle
but it was their next mistake that made
things even worse
from 2009 to 2013 htc
centered its marketing strategy around
two words
quietly brilliant the company believed
that the quality of their products and
the brand would speak for itself
i remember using htc phones back in the
day and thinking that that was true
people just had to use it and then they
would love it
their early phones were second to none
but the thing was
when you asked around no one really knew
who they were
unfortunately this would prove to be a
big problem
while htc was being quietly brilliant
samsung was mocking apple fans in their
advertising
the campaign was a classic and thrust
samsung into the spotlight
it inflamed a war between apple and
android users so large that it only
started to fade just a few years ago
[Music]
by 2011 htc's market share had shrunk in
half
from 67 to 32 while samsung's market
share
grew more than five-fold from four
percent to 27
in the next year samsung was seeing
year-over-year growth as high as 300
percent
and apple 200 meanwhile
htc was practically standing still they
just had a mere 17
of year-over-year growth the naming
schemes of htc phones made things
even worse they had wacky names like
cha-cha
salsa vivid velocity and maze
they even repeated names like the htc
one confusing buyers
is this the new htc one or the old one
for samsung at the time the naming
scheme was simple
their premium phones were just the
galaxy s brand followed by a number
despite winning design awards in 2013
the damage had been done for htc
within the company peter chow's
criticism of managers
along with the hiring of foreign
executives led to morale problems
and confusion over responsibility
in 2013 htc lost their vice president of
global communications
retail marketing manager director of
digital marketing and product strategy
manager
their marketing department was in
shambles there was great upheaval
and disarray within the company
microsoft began to sniff at the
crumbling company
they were in negotiations to purchase
htc
but microsoft would go for nokia instead
by 2015 peter had resigned and cher wang
returned as ceo
things gradually got worse for the
company and in 2015
their share price fell over 60 in that
year and 90
since 2011. it was so low that it fell
off the main exchange in taiwan's stock
index
htc had to cut over 15 percent of its
global workforce as a result
[Music]
it was during this time that chair wang
knew that the company needed a new
direction
so what was she going to do
smartphones were a thing of the past for
them they needed to think of something
new
the answer would be virtual reality
headsets
in collaboration with valve they would
begin manufacturing vr headsets in 2016
and as of today the headset seemed to be
relatively successful in their own right
htc owned about 13 of the vr market
however in 2017 google would step in and
acquire half of their research and
design team
for 1.1 billion dollars in 2018
htc would lay off a further 22 of their
global workforce
currently htc has completely taken their
focus away from phones
and has shifted to emerging technology
virtual reality
blockchain artificial intelligence and
machine learning to name a few
it sounds like it's going to be a tough
road ahead but if they can get a strong
foothold in the vr space or any one of
these spaces
we could see a rise in htc again
in late 2019 eve maita took over a ceo
he remains optimistic about the future
of the company
in q2 of this year hcc posted its fifth
consecutive quarterly loss
uh last july there were some pretty
large
layoffs of the company i think it was
about a quarter of the staff
so my first and i think most important
question for you
is why would anyone want to take this
job
that's a good question if you look at
the balance sheet of the company it's
very strong asset we have
zero debt we have a lot of asset the
side of the brand outside of the ip
outside of the building
we have one billion cash so yes it is a
challenge but we have a lot of strengths
and i personally do believe that there
is a lot to be done
to um to refresh the company and to make
the company being
a leading company in the next in the
next few months and
a few years again i'm i'm strongly
believe
that there is here a fantastic challenge
and and they will anu will get there you
will see we'll get there
htc were once the largest smartphone
vendor in the united states
and the largest android maker globally
their fall
is almost as impressive as their rise
from weak marketing
to poor business moves to unclear
management and confusing naming
the story of htc can tell us something
in the modern world which is so noisy
and loud
a quiet brand that makes great products
isn't enough anymore
if you stand still and think that the
quality will speak for itself
the competition will surpass you before
you know what's happened
so that's the end of htc phones or is it
last year the company stated that they
were going to be making a 5g
phone so we're going to have to watch
this space
so did you know about htc and if so what
was your favorite phone
if you want to see any of my other mini
documentaries on smartphones
i've done one on the individuals that
actually came up with the ideas that
created the iphone
and another one on the rise and fall of
blackberry and one more on the history
of android and ios
but if you're not interested in that i
have hundreds of videos on this channel
that are worth binge watching
so this has been to gogo and you've been
watching cold fusion
i'll see you again soon for the next
episode cheers guys
have a good one
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you